trois d'entre eux régulièrement certains
d'entre eux
le petit matin des faits par les
premiers rayons du soleil
c'est dans ce lieu privilégié que
s'entraînent les surcoûts sur
l'hippodrome de la tête dans le temps
super effectué leur gymnastique
habituels sur les gays les chevaux sont
ainsi préparés aussi bien moralement et
physiquement mais c'est également
valable qui ont précisé que tu es parti
pour s'installer dans cette province
n'est pas si mal à mes yeux c'est une
ambition
monté à paris pour une première chance à
la france hors de l'appareil fonctionne
qu'en date du champion de provence la
flèche la réputation d'être
particulièrement performant il a tissé
de galles ou en terre de bruyère dany
boon comme du velours
le gros poids l'entraînement 15 au total
bino c'est ici la partie des rameaux et
parce qu'il n'est pas plein discours mal
parce que je pense que nous sommes en
train de le faire connaître de mieux en
mieux et nous sommes maintenant
considérer parisienne et s'est
décentralisé seconde et demie il a
considéré que cela demande
certains entraîneurs car l'état ne sont
pas souvent à la hauteur du travail
fourni
les courses et la compétition dans une
fois qu'on a choisi ce métier là il faut
bien considérer que de nos jours les
musiciens de dénis de l'argent mais la
première richesse
les cochons province à mon avis un temps
sont en pleine expansion et ils
programment convergent vers paris mais
on peut très bien débuté une carrière en
province et le fait de la danse chinoise
peut très bien favoriser l'éclosion
d'une carrière à paris où il ya mon
exemple les cinq dernières années
d'autant que wayne a la réputation
d'être berceau d'élevage les meilleurs
chevaux de 5ans france au poignet les
débutants apprennent très vite à mon
genou plutôt original basé sur un
voltige à cheval l'enfance la nourriture
de leurs montures constituant exercices
d'assouplissement en toute liberté
la région naturelle la docilité nos
fermes auberges très vite à nouveau des
citations suivantes sans passer ensuite
à une préparation fut acquis l'essentiel
est acquis
ils n'auront jamais peur à challes qui
concède déjà
il faut toujours se dire l'enfant pourra
toujours ce réflexe je l'espère
d'arriver à commander sa chute un enfant
a quitté son cheval surtout galop il a
pratiquement toutes les chances de
lomagne âge a subi une chute donc de la
commande est lui-même il en sortira même
l'indexation artistes souvent cette
façon de créer à rabais
méditation et si paris si la parité dans
la journée car la guerre sur la sécurité
des promeneurs pour vous emmener dans
leurs éditions de la région parisienne
et sur chaque jour par ce qui se passe
en corée spécialement équipées en e10
est en contact radio
les gendarmes à son efficacité
une patrouille à ce palais encore
recevoir la meilleure forme que le
preneur
puis le traversin familles puissent
venir
le sportif car son joli sans avoir la
crainte je suis là sa voiture est
victime d'un vol voyeur c'est à coup
sans systématiquement composé d'un gars
des dalles qu'il tenait à sa tenue la
gendarmerie un chaman auxiliaires étant
donné le temps relativement court du
service militaire nous n'avons pas le
temps de les former autrement dit je ne
rencontre que des gendarmes auxiliaires
qui ont déjà une pratique du cheval en
mettant d'emblée nous surveillons non
seulement mais également à partir du
quartier carnot derrière le château de
vincennes
nous avons deux postes permanents à sens
et l'autre à son bord nationale et en
plus chaque été et du mois de mai au
mois de septembre
nous mettons en place dans les forêts de
la région parisienne cette place est en
fait une de ses soirées de mai à
septembre
un casque de cinq à dix gardes c'est
exactement de travail
vous saviez vous qu'il existe deux
équipes aux roms en france
des partis qui sont en cause de province
comme celui ci s'élève à 4 briques
manquantes à leur répartition se sont
plaints de bientôt dix ans pour
découvrir la robe très complet indique
aussi les restaurants les curiosités
voilà prochain
quatre tables rondes dont une concernant
la formation des prix elle est une sorte
de pression sur le seul sujet qui parle
à tort qu est le sujet du remboursement
d'un voyage sur le continent pour chaque
fonctionnaire et sa famille une fois par
an alors la négociation a achoppé sur le
montant du remboursement de ce voyage
mais le mois plus tôt hp je suis tout à
fait convaincu
l'ami de chez se rendra elle reprendra
d'ailleurs dans le cadre de la table
ronde 3 connaît tempérament dans un
mauvais sens convaincu que les corps se
comprendront d'abord du groupe à celle
de la france en matière et que le débat
s'ouvrira à nouveau j'ai l'impression
que le gouvernement lui préfère le débat
à long terme et est sur le point de
structures corps ce que vous êtes
d'accord par exemple je propose la rage
me disais ce matin dans le figaro
je n'ai pas au départ sont chers mais
considère que ce sont les intermédiaires
core c'est-à-dire les cordes entre eux
qui a nourri
pas exactement combien de chevaux chacun
qu'ils ne s'inquiètent de savoir comment
utiliser
je crois qu'il faut attendre de la
commission qui chargé dans le cadre
d'une table ronde de savoir comment se
forment les règles de la concurrence
sont avec elle alors je me garderais
camerons de bible la question n'est pas
inquiet ce soir notamment les
organisations syndicales de
fonctionnaires doivent savoir que le
gouvernement tous un véritable problème
c'est qu'on ne peut pas de raison
seulement englobe deux fils là dans un
débat date concernant la formation des
prix concernant l'âge ce tonique et sont
très grosse importance concernant les
primes qu'ils honorent matière de
transports m la place de la peine
d'amendé
des côtes de l'alaska le super pétrolier
américain qui a heurté un récif sont
arrivés sur place mais à la mi-journée
cinq minutes l'après pétrole a démis
déjà les 8 km de long dans une zone la
pêche constitue l'essentiel de
l'économie régionale
le supertanker 300 m de gens ou du tiw
allant de 3 ter intrigue boutabout sept
éventrées déchiré après d'avoir porté un
récit le capitaine s'est écarté de la
route maritime normal pour élites et
d'énormes blocs de glace flottant
les icebergs immédiatement le pétrole et
fait s'écouler des culs à raison de 75
mille litres
chatel plus de la moitié de la cale des
autres 68 s'est répandu sur cette mer
glacée la marée noire s'étend maintenant
surtout de 8 km touché par les ans pour
l'instant dollars
l'accident à une vingtaine de kilomètres
du port de vannes belge sur la côte sud
le premier venu qui approvisionnait les
garde côtes et des secours se sont
rendus sur place mais très tard après la
crise ce qui a déclenché la colère des
pêcheurs et des écologistes
le comptage de l'année les prix si elle
n'est pas respectée
inefficace enfin l'utilisation des
produits chimiques pourraient avoir des
effets catastrophiques sur la faune et
la flore marines particulièrement rudes
dans cette région les équipes d'espoir
sont dessinés mais ne pense pas pouvoir
contenir cette marée noire près de chez
nous dans la manche
pour le moment on se dit pleinement et
pour demain dimanche pour la première
fois en effet depuis l'avènement du
régime plus librement que d'habitude
pour élire une nouvelle chambre des
députés un congrès toutefois il ya
beaucoup à dire sur cette élection lui
entre guillemets car la majorité des
élus sont encore faites par le parti y
est pas
leurs candidatures étaient souvent
souhaité plus officiellement par les
partisans de monsieur gorbatchev pour
assurer cet après midi à moscou se
trouvait justement au milieu de la
dernière manifestation organisée en
faveur de l'un de ses candidats me
morice aura marqué jusqu'au bout une
organisation qui passe pour un modéré et
tous ses failles et le drapeau rouge à
la croix de saint-andré emblème de la
plus ancienne russe yes il n'est pas là
mais le challenge il se présente dans
tout l'arrondissement nous c'est à dire
que 5 millions d'électeurs alors que ce
sera tout ou gênant je n'en mets donc on
va démontrer que la démocratie est en
marche pour l'instant avoir gagné son
pari qui était de laisser la vie
politique sous le contrôle absolu du
parti tout en laissant s'exprimer une
certaine contestation
c'est difficile à faire comprenez
famille c'est comme da libre aux
élections
d'autres exemples
jean marie le premier à démonter
s'occuperont des mécanismes la lumière
un historien entend dissidents ont
délivré son tour ou en partie censurée
et est aujourd'hui candidat aux
élections
le buisson a perdu de candidature ce
sont des pratiques qui s'attaque
ouvertement
regardez notre tente de nous qui n'aura
pas ce jour là l'occasion de l'orient
arabe à rester trois mois pourtant il
est en majorité d'arméniens
la prime pour éviter d'avoir été capable
pendant des mois sur mango
des centaines de milliers de
manifestants en marge de cette élection
voici un exemple des conséquences de la
libéralisation du système soviétique à
l'égard de la religion notamment cette
semaine sont arrivées en russie le
marché était apportée par les frères de
la ville de pézenas
leur objectif n'était pas de réaliser
une affaire financière binaire mais
plutôt d'ordre spirituel reportage
martin et son adresse
avec l'accord des auteurs conforme à
l'origine c'est la seconde partie de la
bible le nouveau testament qui a été
imprimé à l'origine un homme proche de
ma propre projet il ya un an se rend à
la commémoration du millénaire orthodoxe
la matriarche prix le gouvernement
l'introduction unis se lance dans un
gigantesque travail
cameron
exceptionnel va être réduit au maximum
neuf camions sont partis du hms en
carton les mines depuis 2001
en fin de conseil municipal élections
des maires avaient mieux je sais jean
marie bockel
on est en présence d'un véritable cas
d'école puisque dans le conseil en
retrouve le leader écologiste
antoine d'esther des membres du front
national qui ont réalisé près de l
ancien maire de la ville de droit sur
trichant sur place pour cet événement
nous on est socialiste jean marie bockel
un nouveau maire victorieux d'un
deuxième tour à 4 lire tu nous tiens
d'entrée placé son mandat sous
production et d'antoine waechter pour la
première
sur sa droite ouverture ce qui sépare
jean marie bockel n'a pas convaincu le
maire sortant le plus à droite encore
pourtant le front national a pourtant
besoin at il s'est montré plutôt
accueillants mais pour mieux s'en
prendre au maire sortant
les divisions de la droite me gêne qui
ont permis à jean-marie bockel de
l'emporter mais c'est un autre facteur
les conseillers puis front national ont
menacé d'entrer au conseil municipal
contrairement à jour explique cela ils
ont accepté de figurer sur la photo de
famille l'écologiste antoine waechter
également après leur élection il sous
des labels adjoint d'un maire socialiste
mais il pousse ces conditions je retire
à deux conditions la première c'est que
nous puissions garder notre identité
c'est à bien notre liberté d'action et
paramétrer et d'autre part parce qu'elle
me donne réellement les moyens d'être
efficace la pièce jouée la socialiste et
maire de la ville droite droit ne sépare
le plus socialiste l'écologie commence
caliente la chaîne s'est achevée
aujourd'hui à mulhouse comme une
répétition peut-être des élections
européennes l'étranger au liban les
combattants alliés aux syriens bombarde
le pays chrétien l'armée du général aoun
leur répond également avec la retire une
issue à d'ailleurs déclaré qu'il irait
jusqu'au bout dans les cadres au liban
déjà dix jours sa vie il ne quitte pas
de prix
la nuit dernière avec la lettonie ce
matin profitant d'une trêve ils sont
sortis pour constater les dégâts
s'approvisionner plus aucune solution
aussi bien suicidaire at il en est dans
les talons sont tournés vers ce petit
carré rose sur la carte
l'europe est chrétien guerre de
libération contre l'occupation syrienne
soutenues par son mari
cet abattage et sa véritable coeur voir
sa vie leur soutien tu dit ne plus
vouloir entendre parler de réformes et
de l'élection présidentielle alors que
l'occupation marsol m de diversion
capitaine est libanais dixième
anniversaire des accords de camp david
qui ont permis l'établissement d'un
traité de paix entre l'egypte et israël
ne monte pas régler le problème a laissé
une image c'est une rencontre entre les
frères ennemis plus de nouveaux amis le
président égyptien moubarak le roi
hussein de jordanie
yasser arafat pour tenter d'adopter des
communes sur un processus de paix au
prochain un traducteur de versets
sataniques protégée par la police
suédoise
après avoir reçu des menaces de mort
c'est l'écrivain pense également que ses
voisins l'origine malaise qui a été
assassiné la semaine dernière à tulle
être à sa place à la suite d'une tragi
comique
enfin signalons que ce week-end de
plusieurs aéroports et compagnies
aériennes transforce leurs mesures de
sécurité par crainte d'un attentat ou
d'un dépôt ni la société d'informatique
américain ibm a même recommandé d'éviter
de voyager pour certaines destinations
aux états unis le président george bush
réussi à convaincre les parlementaires à
niakhar d'accorder une aide à la résine
président a agi avec discernement et la
fnac rémy qui sera supprimée comme il la
poignarde bouche tout en affirmant
continuer la folie pure et simple et ses
soeurs met surtout en avant le réalisme
hier soir il parvient à un accord avec
la majorité démocrate du congrès local
l'aide humanitaire de 45 millions de
dollars
la résistance nicaraguayenne cru que
regan n'avait pas obtenu
c'est ensuite le nouveau président est
accompagné par l'opposition démocrate
qui annonçait l'aide décidée doit
permettre à la résistance de sigrist et
12 élections démocratiques de 90 annoncé
par managua
là où bush par être payante son
prédécesseur au collet pourrait être
interrompu en cas d'opération munich est
une façon de nous pas trop mécontenter
le gouvernement sandiniste très glam
pour défenseurs de la liberté avec
échoué c'est implicitement reconnu
aujourd'hui en promettant également à
terme la levée de l'embargo économique
qu'ils ont managua grand besoin
kurt busch a davantage de chances de
réussir en france avec un thé vert
reflet d'un véritable problème de
société
une voiture non j'ai déjà subi un
alcootest
il s'agit là malheureusement d'un drame
ordinaire de la prévention routière a
dit dans ces dernières les 18 24 ans
représentent 23 % des tués sur la route
que l'alcool et la vitesse sont les
principales causes de leurs accidents
qui ont lieu le plus généralement les
week-ends chez les cadettes de tombes
dans un cimetière 50 ou au la mito mario
sérieusement entre 14 et 18 ans manuel
23 ans conduisait avec 1 g 25 d'alcool
dans le sang
une fête comme celle ci utilise le nom
des pénis la rue j'aurai toujours le
récurent surcharge et devient
incontrôlable
il faut qu'ils occupent la moitié sont
restés dans le foie ensuite alors il
manuel incarcéré depuis une semaine
ni la police n'est pas en témoigner il
s'appelle cette sympathique soirée comme
les autres alors une appartenance à
partir du moment où il n'y a rien de
structuré pour les jeunes il n'y a pas
les transports il n'y a rien du tout à
part à 80 amusé l'accoutumée pour des
gars rien à la sortie qui vous empêche
de vie des matraques km rien du tout
y a pas de survivant suis pas du tout
services répressifs préventif est pas la
même chose
l'une des victimes travailler dans ce
garage l'intrus copain m'a dit c'est
quelque chose pour nous maintenant
l'adolescent travaille dur ou de prêts
pour leur société et il ya la partie et
ça n'utilise contre cette borne alors
que cette nuit je lis pour une seule
voiture pourquoi ne pas faire le voyage
débutera ainsi de devenir un chiffre de
plus dans les prochaines la france et
l'europe
exception faite de l'angleterre passe à
l'heure d'été à 2 heures du matin il
sera 3 heures la décision comme en 1976
d'économiser l'énergie devenu cher à
traiter la réalité de cette économie n'a
jamais été vraiment prouver qu'ils
peuvent elles avoir des répercussions
notre seul admis en attendant un
éventuel changement qui n'est pas
impossible
l'année prochaine tous les responsables
pour mettre le reportage bahn regio des
rapides chaque changement d'heure c'est
l'homme de la situation
21 ans mark dean ce n'est pas un musée
de la ville de paris est chargé avec son
équipe de 114 de remettre les pendules à
l'heure
ce week-end ils 350 et à 10 ans comme
cette horloge l'une des plus belles de
la capitale a été offerte à paris en
deux fois par an mark higgins il pas
fils à nous alors le garde
demain peut-être la technologie dans les
ordinateurs se chargeront de régler pour
enfin dans nos tranquille n'oubliez pas
donc demain matin d'une heure de moins
alors dernier essai confirmation cet
imprévu de la bonne tenue du moteur
renault qui équipe les milliards
car d'opale 13 partir en effet en
deuxième position derrière la mclaren
d'air china qui a pu même réussi à
garder première comme il a terminé la
saison 90 en la matière en revanche pour
alain prost il a parfaitement les
défauts de la mclaren mais il partira
donc en troisième ligne le handicap
n'est envisagé beaucoup mieux que prévu
en revanche la williams genou après
avoir été le précurseur en matière de
turbo revient à moteur atmosphérique
riccardo patrese également à riom 7
car rené arnoux même international
arrivé cet après-midi premier vous allez
voir c'est les mêmes clients
interroge t il avec hrc cet après midi
vous allez voir les chevaux gagnants
ceux qui souffrent ou 3 le kart est tous
bien le 14 et vous gagnez 80 voilà ce
journal est terminée tout de suite après
les prévisions météo dans la pierre aux
alentours de 23 ans philippe gassot et
puis prend la tendance est bien la
formation change élevé ce soir spécial
belle époque au paradis mais je brûlais
bonne soirée